par Michel maire qui fait son grand
retour
ah là là là ça fait plaisir de le revoir
hein GG même toi qui peux pas le blairer
tu vois
moi aussi ouais vraiment il y a rien à
dire le travail ça ne va pas je suis le
premier à le dire non mais je te jure
c'est beaucoup mieux quand tu travailles
pas mais je sais ton cheveux ta peau est
magnifique tu es bronzé franchement
la nuit du 31 décembre j'ai passé dans
un camion de déménagement à conduire au
moins même le bahut et puis
[Rires]
nouvelle vie nouveau départ 2023
ce soir si j'ai la force de conduire
parce que là je suis en voiture ce soir
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je suis très heureux je me demande
pourquoi j'ai des pas parti plus tôt moi
je regarde tous les soirs et que vous y
sort de rat de rat ça m'a travaillé à la
fin je le voyais plus que ça quand je
pense je sais le mets entre les travaux
les poubelles les rats moi il faut que
je parte et donc comme chéri tu es en
dessous mais je suis parfait la chanson
de Claude François
Sainte-Maxime
[Rires]
il fait beau franchement je me demande
pourquoi je dis tout le temps avec ta
meuf elle travaille la journée
ou pas
en pointillés depuis 10 jours
on est ensemble parfois ça ça
fait 10 ans qu'on est amoureux c'est fou
ouais vous avez vous êtes vraiment
collés
de coller je suis en fin de vie quand
même donc
[Applaudissements]
en parlant de fin de vie beaucoup de
gens me demandent des nouvelles de
Daniel
chéri sachez-le daniel est un petit peu
malade elle reviendra lundi elle a ce
qu'on appelle la chiasse
communément j'arrive
à lundi et elle sera en forme ici à côté
de Gilles juste mondreus de résistance
réglementaire et je mettrai personne
derrière dans le public pour avoir édité
tout accident sinon le reste Daniel va
bien je lui fais un gros bisou ma chérie
voilà il t'inquiète pas tu es de retour
dès que tu peux m'adonner Madani Daniel
très bien alors non mais t'es heureux
alors oui je suis très heureux mais j'ai
dû un papier dernièrement comme quoi
chaque année Paris perdait à peu près
entre 15 et 20 000 personnes attends et
je les comprends parce que franchement
puis avec le covid c'est accéléré mais
là j'ai l'impression de vivre une
nouvelle vie l'air effraie est propre
les gens sont sympas ils sont pas
stressés il fait beau oh je me promène
avec mes chiens au bord de l'eau et
cetera qu'est-ce pourquoi j'ai attendu
71 ans pour vivre mais t'es pas du tout
en fin de vie
dans la force de l'âge je trouve que
dans la force de la France alors ma mère
me dit j'adore Jean-Mi toi
[Rires]
très bonne nouvelle
très bonne nouvelle et parce que je vous
dis exactement ce qui se passe
Olivia Grégoire
sera avec nous mardi
[Musique]
ça bouge merci merci
franchement bravo et génial elle est
incroyable franchement elle viendra elle
répondra à toutes les questions et on
essaiera de faire avancer les choses
franchement c'est beau j'adore ce qu'est
le bonheur quand même c'est fou on est
en direct il y a un mec qui parasite
quoi c'est la vie franchement c'est ça
c'est la vie TPMP c'est la vie le 6/7
aussi j'adore les voir très sympa
dis-moi bébé oui toi en tout cas je suis
très heureux pour toi bah oui moi aussi
et donc ça y est tu reviens plus jamais
tu dépasses non parce que tu déportes
tu t'es parti en Thaïlande c'est comme
si je veux dire je devais acheter un par
dessus et puis finalement j'ai acheté un
slip je devais passer en Thaïlande
quand j'étais célibataire on s'est remis
ensemble le projet Thaïlande est capoté
et du coup je suis parti sur en
Thaïlande tu veux dire que tu as mis des
capotes en Thaïlande
non mais
il y a deux lectures
quand vous m'appelez je viens avec grand
plaisir je vais taper très souvent les
gens t'adore ma mère t'adore ça serait
mieux que ça soit pas le lundi le
mercredi
un peu dans le sud
tu serais pas chauffeur livreur en même
temps
parce que là tu travailles plus toi bah
je travaille qu'on m'appelle
c'est ton seul travail quoi
[Applaudissements]